[Music]
bring me another bottle of Moet towards
your aunt waad apparently the world is
ending
well where is he
[Music]
some types of goddamn beautiful it makes
me want to throw up
I'll get myself
[Music]
and [ __ ] there you are oh this is nerd
ago hey Doc can you bring me my smelling
salt please I'll think about it
have you watched my video yet the one
about the apocalypse no Marie it's not
about the apocalypse it's about how to
stop climate change
you've got damn liberals always want me
to watch some video on YouTube or some
boring transsexual lectures me about
social justice well I can't stand that
well why don't you watch a few minutes
and then I'll bring you your smelling
salts Phyllis extortion you're singing
to us just a shove your liberal agenda
down my throat my god you cooks will
stop at nothing that's right open wide
No welcome to the lab the lab of
aesthetic climatology is it hot in here
or is the world just like this now
imagine that this is the earth this is
what the earth would look like if you
stabbed it with a giant knife in 1976 a
beta [ __ ] named Al Gore led the first
congressional hearings on global warming
for the next several decades he devoted
much of his career to raising public
awareness about the grave predictions of
climate science in particular the
disastrous effects of global warming
induced by industrial carbon dioxide
emissions Gore's activism culminated in
2006 with the release of his documentary
An Inconvenient Truth but a month before
its release
Comedy Central aired an episode of South
Park ridiculing Gore has a hysterical
buffoon obsessed with warning the nation
about a mythological creature called
manbearpig it is half man half bear
and half-pig the episode portrays gore
as a narcissistic attention seeking
alarmist an issue however they care
about a sibilant moral i'm super-cereal
you guys we all had a good laugh at
Gore's foolishness after all no one
likes a complainer a critic a moralist a
killjoy a naysayer the embarr of bad
news and in fact a lot of us probably
remember manbearpig better than we
remember an inconvenient truth a lot of
the backlash against gore seems to fit a
pattern described in the brilliant video
essay why are you so angry by innuendo
studios part 2 of the essay describes a
phenomenon I'll call the angry jak
effect it works like this you're on a
barbecue chef and brisket into your
front hole when you notice the person
seated next to you two clients to eat
any meat because they're vegan your
immediate instinctual reaction is anger
at the vegan because even if they're not
really judging you the mere fact that
they're a vegan means that they probably
have reasons for not eating meat and
that means there might be reasons why
you shouldn't leave me so what you do is
you lash out at the vegan and you tell
them oh so you think you're better than
me ha well I'll have you know that
eating meat is perfectly natural and
evolution and people who don't eat meat
well their bones fall out and besides
you're a hypocrite anyway because more
animals die when they plow the fields
for your stupid [ __ ] vegetables you
moral jerk of course this is all really
a rational response to the situation
this is you subconsciously protecting
your ego from potential guilt from the
potential accusation that you're a bad
person and you're protecting the
lifestyle that you enjoy and are
accustomed to from a potential threat
and this is essentially how people have
been reacting to Al Gore for decades
he's a fun ruiner criticizing our high
emission way of life and instead of
engaging sincerely with the critique we
lash out at him so we don't have to
think about it the problem is that
scientifically speaking climate change
is in fact real and Gore was right all
along
scene oopsie
so now its current year and the global
temperature has risen one degree Celsius
above the pre-industrial average which
is on track with the projections
presented in Gore's film now one degree
doesn't sound like much but to get a
sense of scale consider that the last
ice age was only 4.5 degrees Celsius
cooler than the 20th century norm we are
already at 1 degree warmer than the
pre-industrial average and current
scientific models put us on track for 3
degrees warmer by the end of the century
an outcome that would among other
catastrophes completely flood Shanghai
and Miami scientists have long
recommended that we limit warming to 2
degrees in order to avert global
Cataclysm but the latest report from the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change warns that even two degrees of
warming could result in an iceless
Arctic summer at least once a decade the
destruction of nearly every coral reef
and a heightened frequency of tropical
cyclones droughts and famines around the
world the report therefore recommends
that we limit warming to 1.5 degrees the
goal that requires drastic and
unprecedented reduction in emissions
within the next 12 years and net zero
emissions by 2050 but even limiting
warming to two degrees requires a
significant reduction in emissions
otherwise we're on track look dawg
this is the same liberal media [ __ ]
we've all heard for decades weather
changes sometimes you were just talking
about the obese age first it was cold no
it's getting warmer that's just nature
do you honestly think that all the
world's leading climate scientists just
forgot to take into account that weather
changes sometimes isn't it obvious to
you that this whole guilt trip about
carbon emissions is just an attack on
the American Way of life another excuse
for big government to take away my
freedom what freedom are you an oil
company well what if i sexually identify
as an oil company isn't that what you
liberals think my identity is valid no
it isn't bring me the lake smelling salt
watch the goddamn video
imagine the year is 2100 I want you to
picture the earth as a human vagina and
imagine you're a gynecologist and you're
using a speculum to examine the inside
of a watermelon how does that make you
feel kids but you wish your
irresponsible gas guzzling parents had
done something to stop this so we may
have a global climate catastrophe fast
approaching but at least our political
leaders are responsible rational and
scientifically literate right is their
climate change yeah will it go back like
this I mean will it change back probably
that's what I think I believe it goes
this way Donald Trump has a consistent
history of climate change denial from
his 2012 claim that global warming is a
Chinese hoax aimed at undermining
American manufacturing to his tweet last
week that it's very cold outside
therefore whatever happened to global
warming of course the term global
warming refers to the increase in the
global average temperature temperature
continuing to vary by region in fact
global warming could cause some regions
to become much colder for instance if
the ocean current known as the Atlantic
conveyor belt is disrupted chilling the
North Atlantic and potentially making
European winters more severe but Trump
doesn't know or care about any of that
he's kind of the anti Al Gore you know a
real man who takes what he wants by any
means necessary and won't be slowed down
by any worries about what's factual or
scientific or true or good or consensual
or just are safe for legal or even
possible he's the kind of man who
Americans collectively want on some sub
rational erotic level to brutally
dominate us like an ancient Chinese God
Emperor Bern the scholars built the wall
with the problem at least for those of
you who don't actively enjoy
civilizations plunge into primeval
darkness is that the notion that there's
any actual scientific controversy about
the role of carbon emissions and global
warming is simply false
a 2013 analysis of the scientific
literature on climate change found that
97% of papers published on the subject
supported the conclusion that humans
caused global warming and the consensus
has only increased over time climate
change denial is considered an oddity in
Europe but is very common in the mare
largely as a result of a massive
campaign of manufactured uncertainty and
listen firm ation that goes back to the
early 1990s when the Western fuels
Association developed a strategy to
quote reposition global warming as
Theory not fact and spent half a million
dollars researching the most effective
way to promote that message via a
propaganda campaign climate denialists
talking points promoted by organizations
in the subsequent decades have been
statistically linked to funding from
ExxonMobil and the Koch family and
denialism has been frequently pushed by
Republican politicians perhaps most
vocally Senator James Inhofe whose
campaigns are financed by oil and energy
companies and who's presented on the
Senate floor such compelling arguments
as throwing a snowball tone the lifts so
mr. president this mm-hmm denialists
talking points have trickled down from
the reptilian overlords to the ordinary
youtube comment goblins where they
provide ammunition for the angry jak
effect just like Al Gore or any
messenger of inconvenient information
climate scientists themselves have for
years been targets of endless harassment
Michael Mann the original publisher of
the hockey stick graph has received
thousands of hate messages death threats
even white powder in the mail the mental
health of many climate scientists is
actually suffering as a result of
harassment denial the Bleak political
situation and the daily grind of
studying a cataclysmic future it's
likely that this video will attract some
deniers and I therefore invite my
audience to use the denialist debunking
resource listed in the top comment below
to refute such claims as there's still
scientific controversy about the cause
of climate change there isn't what if
the Sun is getting hotter it's not at
least in the relevant time frame and
science is a liar sometimes even if you
don't believe in science maybe you'll
find it convincing that even many oil
companies including Exxon Mobil now
acknowledge climate change is real and
caused by human activity in fact at the
behest of oil companies the state of
Texas is now seeking at least 12 billion
dollars in public funds to build a
60-mile spine of sea walls along the
Gulf Coast largely to protect oil
refineries from rising tides and more
severe tropical storms after hurricane
Harvey Texas lobbied Congress for 61
billion dollars to quote future-proof to
state despite the fact that many of its
top politicians are public climate
change deniers remember how it used to
be called global warming and then
magically the theory change due climate
change sure the reason is it wasn't
warming do not listen to the Kant of
these sneering Reptoids the science is
clear
climate change is real and humans are
causing it if even ExxonMobil says it's
real it's probably real there's really
no point in digging in your heels and
refusing to look at the evidence just
because you don't want to be ok fine so
maybe the world is getting and maybe
humans has something to do with it
now can you give me my smelling salts
fine look dawg I gotta say maybe the
scientists are right maybe it is
happening but to be honest with you I'm
having a hard time caring about this
like at all how can you not care about
this we're talking about the future of
the planet well I don't care about the
planet I care about me well don't you
live on the planet mm-hmm and don't you
care what happens to the planet you live
on no god damn it watch the video if you
picture the earth as a watermelon you
can see there's the outer shell here
that traps the red flesh and if you
leave it out at midnight the stalkers
this doctor is coming for the red flash
before describing the details of our
doom let's take a moment to review how
we got where we are the modernist
science of anthropogenic climate change
began in 1896 when a Swedish science
jerk called sponte Jorge Gnaeus
published a study titled on the
influence of carbonic acid in the air
upon the temperature of the earth in
which he predicted the industrial carbon
dioxide production would eventually have
a warming effect on the planet by 1960
scientists had demonstrated that the
level of co2 in the atmosphere was in
fact rising and President [ __ ]
Johnson's Science Advisory Committee
warned that industrial co2 emissions
could have a greenhouse warming effect
the Stanford Research Institute warned
the American Petroleum Institute in 1968
that continued emissions would lead to
Antarctic melting and rising
see levels but nothing was really done
about it until 1988 when NASA announced
to the US Senate that the earth was
warmer than any time in modern history
that the warming could be attributed to
human causes with 99% certainty that the
warming was worsening heat waves storms
and droughts that same year the IPCC was
formed to provide world leaders with a
summary of the science on climate change
and its political and economic impacts
so it started to seem like something was
going to change but by the early 1990s
the oil and energy funded climatology
denial industry was up and running in
the United States despite the fact that
oil companies had known climate change
was happening for decades and Republican
politicians became mouthpieces for the
so-called skeptic cause meanwhile the
Clinton administration signed the Kyoto
Protocol pledging the United States to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions a pledge
that the Bush administration then
refused to make good on the 2012
Republican platform stated against all
scientific consensus that quote the
causes and long-range effects of a
phenomenon are uncertain an opposed
regulation of greenhouse gas emissions
then finally in 2015
things seemed to be changing for the
better 195 nations including China India
and the United States under Obama became
parties to the Paris agreement which
established the goal of limiting the
increase in global temperature to well
below two degrees Celsius for the very
next year Donald Trump was elected
president for the United States when a
platform of outright climate science
denial Trump has since begun withdrawing
the United States from the Paris
agreement appointed a climate change
denier the head of the Environmental
Protection Agency and released his
America first energy plan which
encourages unregulated burning of fossil
fuels so it's with a particular sense of
doom that we now receive the grim 2018
IPCC report which informs us that the
world has already warmed 1 degrees
Celsius
resulting in significant melting of both
polar ice caps increased average
temperatures increased extreme weather
events and increased mosquito-borne
illnesses like malaria dengue and Zika
if drastic action is taken to reduce
carbon emissions 49% by 2030 and to net
zero carbon by 2050 global warming will
still increase to 1.5 degrees above the
pre-industrial average resulting in a
doubling of
populations exposed to water scarcity
and drought and an estimated 10 trillion
dollars in annual flood damage losses
from sea-level rise
but with the current political situation
the goal of reducing warming to 1.5
degrees is quickly slipping above reach
but the end of the century were likely
to see at least 2 degrees of warming
which will lead to the eventual
displacement of 200 million people in
coastal regions three degrees of warming
will flood many of the world's major
coastal cities including Shanghai and
Miami
Osaka Rio de Janeiro Alexandria and Hong
Kong 4 degrees of warming will be close
to the difference between early 20th
century temperatures in the last ice age
a global crisis of hundreds of millions
of refugees from Island and coastal
areas will be exacerbated by severe
droughts and water scarcity trillions of
dollars of damage to the economy famines
starvation terrorism and war so it's not
just the poor polar bears and coral
reefs there are real human consequences
to this see this is why you should care
it's not just about the planet it's
about the millions of people who are
gonna die or lose their homes
oh jeez wow that's gosh that's really
just too bad what kind of response is
that look doc people die all the time
what am I supposed to do cry about it
know what you're supposed to take
political action yeah I guess I could
but this bath is barely relaxing well
look even if you only care about
yourself you do realize that when the
coastal cities flood we're gonna have to
take in tens of millions of refugees
right are you gonna be ok with that
no well then you'd better do something
to reduce carbon emissions No well then
you'd better be ready to take it a lot
of refugees know you do realize right
that in a hundred years everyone is
going to look back on people like you
and they're gonna hate you so much for
what you allowed to happen to this
planet well those are future people I'm
alive now and besides and what you're
saying is true then this is basically
the apocalypse anyway so why not just
party and enjoy ourselves right but it's
not the apocalypse though call it the
epochal
is literally just another form of
denialism because we still have a little
bit of time to fix the problem please
God please just try to focus on solving
the problem we still have time so you're
saying the world is something cheers to
that
the world is not ending its just getting
shittier well what am I supposed to do
about it let's watch an instructional
video to learn more all right let me
just reappear
ah all right dog put it in me you're
repulsive what so sorry you're offended
by pleasure I'm not offended by what
this offends you doesn't make are you
favorite liberal are you bring her home
I'm not triggers stop trying to pretend
you're not home you know you really
shouldn't be supporting the dairy
industry they caused a massive carbon
emissions well maybe you shouldn't be
supporting the clothes industry
hypocrite why it's so milk anyway
science nerd how do you think I got so
feminine there's nothing in science to
support that just admit that you're
offended please just watch the video
when I was a little girl I used to sit
on the porch eating watermelon and I'd
stare up at the stars and wonder where
did they all come from you know what
does this all mean the cosmos humanity
our little time here on earth and that's
why I became a scientist so I can spend
my life studying top aspheric trace
gases
[Music]
if you want to do your part to stop
climate change there are some lifestyle
changes you can make you can use LED
light bulbs you can drive a hybrid or
electric car you can use public
transportation you can try not to fly
very often you can eat less red meat so
the reality is just 100 companies are
responsible for 71 percent of global
emissions and the burden of stopping
this can't really be placed on
individual consumers the companies
themselves do not care left to their own
devices they will only pursue short-term
profit they will ask the government to
build them sea walls while continuing to
emit greenhouse gases climate change is
exactly the kind of problem that
capitalism is really ill-equipped to
solve the timeframe involved is short
enough that scientists can predict total
catastrophe in the foreseeable future
but just long enough not to enter into
the shareholder pleasing decision-making
of corporations so unless there's a
drastic change in the next couple
decades this is going to be capitalism's
great Chinese famine moment only
potentially it'll be much much worse
this is probably the most important
issue facing humanity in the 21st
century so we kinda need to fix it by
any means necessary
beginning with rapid political change if
that means direct action it means direct
action for instance organizing
participating in or supporting a massive
general strike you also should demand
that your politicians take a strong
stance against climate change and the
companies that caused it and if your
American vote this monumental dingdong
of the Oval Office in 2020 before the
entire planet shrinks and transforms
into a corncob
so let me get this straight
you want me to go vegan dry our Prius
and vote Democrat you're basically
asking me to completely change who I am
as a person and become everything I hate
yeah pretty much
but it's not about what I want it's
about what everyone has to do to
preserve the survival of humanity
well electric cars veganism who can even
afford that [ __ ] maybe you could afford
a new drink less champagne I shall do no
such thing
well maybe you could drink Prosecco I
will not stoop to drinking Italian
dishwater you know eating plant-based
meals actually costs less than eating me
okay so just never again enjoy the
morning aroma of bacon sizzling on the
skillet barbecued ribs fried chicken
corndogs spicy pork belly lamb chops
bloody stinks you why do you want to eat
all that murdered animal flesh anyway
when you could eat pure clean and
natural foods like lentils barley and
sprouts
I'd rather eat human shed well that's
what you're gonna be eating if the
planet heats another few degrees how am
I supposed to care about rising sea
levels when there's Muslims out there
and Mexicans there could be Muslim
Mexicans for all I know
why is racist paranoia so compelling to
you when all the climate science in the
world just bounces off that thick skull
of yours so first of all you people
think everything is racist and second I
guess I just need a villain you know
who's the bad guy Who am I afraid of
what's the other team your climate story
has no antagonist is that really what
it's gonna take all right then why don't
you take a long hard look out at the sea
mama that's right there she is now
looking right over there
hello mankind it is I your dark mother
the see and to you my children have been
an absolute disappointment every one of
you is so pathetic you make me want to
throw up
politicians businessmen and worst of all
environmentalists ah the condescension
of it all you think you are capable of
hurting me ha I enjoy your so-called
degradation your filthy air makes me hot
you're melting glaciers fill me up deep
inside when you spew your filth all over
oh it only makes me [ __ ] white
every year my heaving bosom encroaches
farther on your Shores
and as I spat you out my children I will
swallow you all I will take every inch
of you inside me and I will suck you
down into the deep black pit of my
wetness you scum and why because I am a
[ __ ] my progeny encompass the earth and
whatsoever I create I shall destroy for
I your deep dark mother and at once
deliver us of your doom and that's why I
vote Republican
[Laughter]
you see that we've got 20 years to stop
her or we're [ __ ]
[Music]